نديم اسرائيل سخرت الكثير من مواردها في
حرب غزه برايك ما اهم هذه الموارد صحح
برايي اهم مورد هو العنصر والعامل البشري
هي سخرت ولكن خسرت شوي حنحكي عن خسرت كيف
ولكنها سخرت 360,000 من جنود الاحتياط عشر
هذه القوى العامله يعمل في قطاع
التكنولوجيا وهو عصب الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
معروف عنهم من ذوي الانتاجيه العاليه اذا
هم محترفين خسرتهم السوق وتعطلت هذه القوى
العامله ايضا النصف الاخر من هذه القوى
العامله يعملون في قطاع الانتاج الصناعي
وقدرتهم وانتاجيته تفوق اربع مرات نظرائهم
في الدول الغنيه اذا هذا الجانب هي خسرت
فيه على الرغم من انها جيشت هذا هذه القوى
العامله لصالح الاحتياطي الجيش ايضا هناك
000 عامل اجنبي تركوا البلاد بسبب المخاوف
من قيام هذه الحرب
كانت ه هذه العماله تعمل في الرعايه
الصحيه وايضا في المزارع في المزارع هناك
في اسرائيل ليس هناك اشخاص من يقومون على
سبيل المثال بالتقاط ثمار هذا الموسم اين
خسرت ايضا اسرائيل في موضوع القوى العامله
هناك 200 ال فلسطيني يعملون في الداخل في
من ذوي المهارات ال منخفضه او المتوسطه
هؤلاء وبحسب صندوق النقد الدولي في
الانتفاضه الثانيه في عام 2000 وخمسه
كانوا احد اسباب تعطل وكبح جماح النمو في
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي اذا هي ارادت استخدام
هذا العنصر لصالح الحرب على غزه ولكن في
المقابل كانت هناك تداعيات سلبيه على
الاقتصاد